today I'm going to talk about the 7
things you can do today to make more
money every day so one of the most
common questions that I get asked some
entrepreneurs is how do I make more
money with my business right how can I
get more customers how can I Drive it
forward I have this big idea how kind of
execute on it and one of the things that
I need to do every single day to help me
realize my goal so today I'm going to
share with you the 7 things that you
should be working on every single day in
your business to help you grow number
one is to fix your mindset it's so easy
to get stuck in your day-to-day life in
your day to day living in the you know
little man inside your head and the
little man all around you where you need
to be thinking bigger you need to
believe that you can do something bigger
not just happen to watch a video and
you're on fire for that day and you wake
up and you're starting from scratch
again every day every single day you
need to create a routine habits a system
that makes your mindset give you the
courage and confidence and passion and
belief that you can go and do something
bigger that's why I recommend starting
your day with the interesting series I
made that for myself to adjust my own
mindset every single morning so I turn
it on and I'm thinking bigger I'm
getting some sprinkles of advice and
wisdom from someone who's done a lot
more but you need to start your day
every single day with the right mindset
to help you go and accomplish something
bigger because all of the strategies and
all the other advice in the world won't
help you until you get the right mindset
number two was build alliances I always
say the fastest way to build a company
is to partner up form alliances with
people who already have your target
audience so think about the customers
that you're trying to reach think about
who is already selling to them who
already has that base of customers so
instead of you going out 1 1 1 1 1 at a
time trying to reach customers you're
now connecting with an influencer who
they like what you're doing they can
introduce you to tens hundreds thousands
hundreds of thousands millions of people
it's much more efficient it's a
fantastic use of time and it's your
fastest way to grow your company number
3 is spend time helping a customer you
should be doing this every day look at
the people who are buying from you look
at the people who are leads look at the
people who are leaving comments on your
social channels find a way to give back
and help them you want to create
goodwill you want to create a sense of
you know this person cares about me they
like me they want me to do well they
care about the problems that I'm going
through and if you help a customer every
single day you'll build up a lot of
word-of-mouth you'll build up a lot of
chatter you build up a lot of goodwill
towards your business and you need to do
it this is why I spend time every single
day in my youtube comments from you guys
one because it's a good you know
business thing to do but to like I enjoy
it right it makes me feel good and will
help you feel good knowing that you're
giving back and helping somebody out
even if it doesn't lead to a sale
because that will come back to you
whether that person eventually comes and
buys or they tell their friends about
you by doing good and helping your
customers out it will come back to you
and you need to dedicate time every
single day to making that happen
number four is connect on social media I
would pick the channel that you feel
most comfortable with whether it's
YouTube or Twitter or LinkedIn or
Facebook or snapchat whatever it is
spend time every day creating content
not just consuming don't just be a
consumer because you don't make money
being a consumer right you need to make
money by producing something you need to
make money by creating the content and
so if you are into videos put up a
YouTube video or at least be working on
YouTube video every day connect with
your audience engage with them connect
with other people on the social media
platforms fans are the people that you
look up to right start building that
platform in that connection every single
day and so focus on shifting your
perspective from just being a consumer
of social media to being a creator
yourself because that's how you're gonna
add value to other people's lives and
spread the word about your business
number five is practice practice
practice whatever it is that you want to
be good at chances are you're not yet
the best in the world at it and if you
want to make money you want to have a
big impact then you need to be among the
best in the world at what you do it's
okay that being itched out right like
you are the best ping-pong paddle
creator whatever it is right like you
need to niche yourself in but you need
to be really really good at what you do
right if you look at my youtube channel
you can go back and see my videos and
how bad I was at the start compared to
now because I've practiced and I
practice and I practice and I've done
over 3,000 videos and most of them are
live on the channel and you need to
dedicate time every day to work on your
craft to make you better at what you do
whether that's in your product whether
that's in your service whatever it is a
personal development growth thing that
you're working on you need to spend time
you need to factor that in every day to
help you become the best in the world at
what you do making money comes from
providing value providing value comes
from having the experience and the
experience come from practicing
practicing practicing practicing sucking
and slowly getting better until you've
reached the top
number six is improve your product so
many people launch a product or they
launch a service and then they don't
touch it for a long time when they start
to degrade where you need to be
constantly adding more things into your
product into your service to make it
better to make it to make it more
nourishing for you because you're
challenging yourself to add something
more in right as entrepreneurs we like
coming up with the ideas and we like
executing on it we're doing the same
thing over and over and over again it
starts to get boring we start to check
out but also it adds value to your
customers so you need to constantly
tweaking constantly doing experiments
they're not always gonna be a big huge
new thing that you're launching but
little tweaks I'm always changing things
on my You Tube channel as an example
since you guys know me through YouTube
I'm changing around the titles I'm
changing around my introduction and
change around how I present this is a
new series that I started right now tell
me what you guys think right and it's a
combination for me of one do you guys
enjoy it and like it and two do I like
it doesn't make me come alive am i
finding joy in doing this what I'm doing
now and when I lose that passion
excitement I'll move on and do something
else
you constantly to be doing tests and
experiments and making your product or
service and better every single day
and number seven is be grateful a lot of
entrepreneurs we're pushing for more we
want to accomplish more we have these
big goals and we're frustrated that
we're not getting there faster you know
I want to hit a million subscribers on
my youtube channel we're doing like 30
km month it's too too slow for me I
wanted to go faster I'm trying to figure
out ways to get it pumped up a little
bit faster and I get that stress as an
entrepreneur but I'm equally also
grateful for everything that's happened
in my life you know I'm grateful for the
team I have for the lifestyle I have for
the country that I live in part of what
I do with the team that I have here is
everyday we have a private Facebook
group we will share three things that
we're grateful for and it just helps you
again set the perspective give you the
proper mindset it helps you just deal
with life better because no matter how
bad your day is today I guarantee you
some people have it worse a lot of
people have it worse most of the world
probably has it worse then your worst
day and keeping that in perspective at
least for me helps give me the
confidence to courage the energy to keep
going and it's a daily habit that I try
to practice that sets my right side up
properly and I hope you guys can at
least give it a shot for the next week
three things every day write it down
that you're grateful for and just try to
feel it you know like write it down and
actually just think about it for five
minutes and at least for me I find that
it makes me almost a totally different
person puts my perspective in check and
helped set me up for the day so that's
my take on the several things you could
do today to make money every day in your
business I'd love to know which of the
seven resonates most with you and I'd
love to know what you might add to the
list leave in the comments below I'm
curious to find out I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon